in many parts of ghana especially in
rural areas having access to electricity
is a big challenge some rural
communities still live in the dark today
making it difficult for students to
study at night among others however it
gets exciting to know there are people
who are working hard behind scenes to
help bridge this gap
meet mustafa a young onion who is making
electrical streetlights with renewable
energy and recycled materials hi my name
is mustafa and i build speedlite using
renewable in it let me show you how
so for this build we have some solar
panels we have some pvc pipes
we have some led lights
and then of course some few electronics
and then lithium ion batteries
you also need some tools as well some of
the two that might come in handy are
a glue gun
you need this plier
and then you also need
a blade
for cutting
and
finally you need a pcb board to assemble
all your electronics components
so
let's get started you first of all have
to
fix all your led lights
on the pcb board this way
now this particular one is a 24 volt led
which is more brighter but you can make
a much
lower one
which can
run on very small power like 12 volts or
6 volt for instance
i have
a 12 volt led
[Music]
all right this
this one is a 12 volt led
it is powered by a 12 volt lithium ion
battery and we have
[Music]
this circuit
which automatically switches
the leds on and off during the day time
and nighttime respectively these lithium
ion batteries are actually recovering
these old laptop batteries which are
referred to as condemned by this in the
market a lot of people don't really know
that they are still usable even if even
after
not being able to power the laptop so
i'm going to break this off and then
remove them and test their voltages
one of this voltage
newly manufactured is around 3.7 volts
but after using it in a laptop for a
while there will be a voltage drop
usually
these voltage drops are not too high
that they cannot power anything so let's
go
[Music]
so now
we have finally removed
the lithium ion itself
so what we go on to test the voltages to
see whether they are still
working
with our volt meter or the multimeter we
set it up to the dc voltage over here
now we expect to get around 3.5
to below somewhere 2.8 2.5
this is around 3.6 volts
and earlier
so this one has very small voltage drop
so
we can use it let's start by assembling
the star for the units
and now that's it
you're almost done
with your split legs
now
with the help of the glue gun
you heat it up to the required
temperature to load it
apply
some here
after application
you stick it up
here this one
hold it in position secondly
[Music]
you pick
your
plastic bottles and you fix it in this
room
[Music]
after you are done
you wire up
the circuit
of the bulb first
inside
the plastic bowl
or you can also
put this in position
apply some glue around it for you to
stick first before you put this
inside
now after you connect it up
you cut out these pieces of wire
we joined from these
two wires over here and then connected
to the led bulbs
i'm holding right now
so at the end
you connect the solar
panel
to
another model charging
i first of all design this model
on the breadboard first to test how
efficiently it will charge my
lithium-ion batteries for me i've
already developed the circuit and very
soon i'll bring the pcb out
now when you are done you remove it and
also solder them on top of a pcb board
this way
now the final part you now connect the
solar panel to the charging unit so the
solar panel provides power
through the charging units the charging
unit will charge
the lithium ion batteries now the
lithium ion battery also discharges
power through
the switch
then the switch also control the
switching on and off of the light and
you are done with the street light
mustafa has deployed some of his works
and communities in the northern part of
ghana
reach out to him in case you want to
support his work
[Music]